>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen,
and thank you all so
very much for coming.
It's a very special occasion today,
and we have a very exciting
program ahead of us.
So I am delighted that
we're able to be now here.
And I would like before I start
to recognize the [inaudible],
who is here with us
and who has been one
of our speakers many
-- a few years ago.
And I hope he will come again.
And Princess Masente [phonetic],
and Princess Zeble [phonetic],
who are both here as well, who have
joined us for this presentation,
a presentation which is very
special on the imperial exile
of Emperor Haile Selassie.
And this program is part of
the programs that we have
when we invite speakers, scholars
to tell us about the history
of the countries that we
are responsible for here
at the Library of Congress.
Ethiopia is one of the very
special countries for this division.
We have a specialist just for
Ethiopia, and he, Fantahun Tiruneh,
has collected materials, and built
a recollection at the Library
of Congress, which is one of the
top collections in the world.
And we often have many scholars,
researchers from all over the world
who come to consult
these collections.
And so this division -- I
always make a little commercial
for our division, because our
division is the African Middle
East Division.
It is responsible for 78
countries around the world.
And our collections
are in the vernacular.
They are housed, preserved in our
stacks, which are closed stacks,
and which we use to
serve our patrons
and our researchers as they come.
These countries that
we're responsible for,
or whose collections
come from the whole continent of
Africa, north and Sub-Saharan.
They come from the Middle East,
including the Arab
world, Turkey and Iran.
They include the Hebraic
world, which is very broad
because those connections
come from all over the world.
They also include central
Asia and the caucuses.
And our work here is to serve
our patrons and our researchers,
not only by recommending collections
by pulling the books
off the shelves,
by letting them know
what treasures we have,
but also by having displays,
exhibits, programs, conferences,
briefings, especially
one-on-one briefings.
We receive visitors
from all over the world
who come to use our materials.
We work with different universities,
government agencies and others.
And I'm leaving the best for
last, we invite scholars,
and we invite authors and
writers to come and tell us
about their research,
about their work,
about the collections they have
used, and about the stories
from the countries that
we're responsible for.
It is they who make those
collections come alive,
through their own experiences,
through their photographs,
through the works that they have
done, and through their own passion
for the countries they
have written about.
And so we have a case
in point today.
We have Keith Bowers, a
BBC writer and author,
who has written an exceptional
book, "Imperial Exile:
Emperor Haile Selassie
in Britain," 1936-1940.
The book will be available
for purchase later on.
And now I want to introduce our own,
Fantahun Tiruneh, the specialist
for Ethiopia and Eritrea, who
is a librarian, a scholar,
and who has singlehandedly built an
Ethiopian collection at the Library
to be one of the best in the
United States and in the world.
So Fantahun will introduce
the speaker.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Fentahun Tiruneh:
Thank you, Mary-Jane.
Ladies and gentlemen, I
once again welcome you
to our beautiful reading room
for this tremendous event.
And personally I'm very,
very happy for today's event,
because it has drawn
a lot of scholars
that I have met for so many years.
And some of my teachers, such as
Dr. Mulugeta [phonetic], are here.
And very good friends
that I have lost
for some time have shown up today.
And I especially recognize Princess
Masente, Princess Zeble, and Dr. --
Prince Emias [phonetic], for
making themselves available today
for this event.
And I am very grateful
to David Reta [phonetic],
who has made the important
connection between me
and Keith Bowers, our guest today.
Before I go into introducing
today's guest,
I'd like to make an announcement
that this event is being videotaped,
and later broadcast on the
Library's webcast and other media.
There will be a formal question and
answer period after the lecture,
in which the audience is encouraged
to ask questions and offer comments.
Please be advised that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcasted
as part of this event.
By participating in the question and
answer period, you are consenting
to the Library's possible
reproduction
and transmission of your remarks.
With that said, I would
also like to inform you
that the book signing will take
place in this very room right
after Mr. Bowers' presentation.
I now will introduce our guest.
Mr. Keith Bowers is a former BBC
executive producer, a writer,
an international broadcast
correspondent.
At the BBC Mr. Bowers ran two
international television documentary
series, assignments and
correspondent, and at one stage was
in charge of all the BBC's
international current affairs
outputs on television, domestic,
radio, and world service.
He worked for 20 years for the BBC.
For nine months in 2014, he
was based in Washington, DC,
working as an executive
producer for Al Jazeera.
He has also taught journalism to
students at a number of universities
around the world, including
[inaudible] University,
City University in London,
and New York University.
Mr. Bowers has worked extensively
in Ethiopia over the past 15 years.
He has taught in the School of
Journalism and Communication
at [inaudible] University,
and I'm glad to announce
that Avi Fort [phonetic], my best --
my good friend, was the dean
when Mr. Bowers was a lecturer
at the university, and has worked
with young documentary makers
as part of the Ethiopian
Field Initiative.
He is the author of two books,
his first book, "Viewing History,"
which is an eyewitness account
of key movements of change,
and "Imperial Exile," of course the
one that we are discussing today.
Mr. Keith Bowers is based
in the United Kingdom
as a broadcast consultant, and
now lives in the city of Bath.
Please welcome Keith Bowers.
[ Applause ]
>> Keith Bowers: [Speaks
Foreign Language].
[Laughter] Welcome to everybody.
[ Speaks Foreign Language ]
So it's a great pleasure and honor
to be here in this wonderful,
marvelous, inspiring building.
When I was in Washington in 2014, I
came here and was inspired to study
and learn, just by the
walls and the books.
It's a fantastic place to be.
It's great also to have
friends, and colleagues,
and members of the emperor's
family as well, and especially
to Princess Zeble, who helped
me in the writing of this book.
We had two interview sessions
at Annandale, and we also met
on Kings Road in Chelsea.
So we're meeting again
in a different place.
And it's a pleasure to
meet Prince Emias as well.
We communicated by
e-mail, and the princess,
his mother too, it's
great to meet you.
And Abby Ford and David Greta, and
I have some friends I worked with,
Josh and Cody, when I was here,
and thank you so much for coming.
It's rather appropriate, I
think, that we're talking
about His Imperial
Majesty, the emperor
and his exile period
in the United States.
But the story I'm telling
happened in Britain primarily.
But there were many links between
the emperor and the United States.
As you know, he met President
Roosevelt in 1944 at Bitter Late
on a destroyer, and was
the first African leader
to have a tickertape
reception on Broadway,
where more than a million
people turned up to welcome him.
And, of course, there were
links with the Americans
with the Foundation of Ethiopian
Airlines, which is now one
of the most successful
airlines in Africa,
that was instigated
with American help.
So there are many links.
And I learned yesterday, excitedly,
that the emperor also visited
the Library of Congress.
And lurking somewhere in these ogost
[phonetic] buildings is actually a
hand-drawn map by his Imperial
majesty, 1921, a map of Ethiopia
and it's in store here
somewhere, so yes.
But that's not the subject
of the lecture today.
That's a different
lecture, the relationship
between America and Ethiopia.
Today we're going to be talking
about His Imperial
Majesty's exile time in Bath.
And the way I'm going to do this is
look at why did he end up in Britain
in the first place, what happened to
him while he was there in the 1930s,
and then how did he come to leave?
It's a big story.
And, of course, the emperor was
in power for many, many years,
so we're not touching on a lot
of the aspects of his reign.
We're just focusing on
the exile experience.
Why was I interested in this?
Well, I think first of all,
the exile experience is a
universal human condition.
Throughout history, people
have been refugees forced
from their countries.
And today, as we know, this
is a very commonplace thing.
So I was very excited to look at
this through the eyes of one person,
what was it like to be in exile?
Of course, as we know the background
to this, the emperor came to Britain
in 1936 after Italy had invaded
Ethiopia a few months before.
So this was a time of war
and international aggression,
all issues of collective
security and peace,
and having to protect the weak
from the strong, and the powerful,
all of these are relevant.
But most of all, I
wanted to write this story
because it's a fascinating story.
It's a mingling of two cultures,
two countries at an incredible time
in world history, the 1930s.
And I think thank you to the
Library of Congress for inviting me
and I think, as Fenta said,
I live in Bath myself,
which is why I wanted to write
this book, because that's
where the emperor lived for
most of his time in Britain.
And Bath itself is a
fascinating historical city.
Anyway, now we're going
to have a few slides.
I hope I can operate them.
You know the old joke about
President Ford that could he walked
down the streets and chew
gum down at the same time,
I'm now going to test
whether I can speak
and operate this at the same time.
[Inaudible], we'll see what happens.
So the picture you have in front
of you here is one of my favorites.
I don't know whether you've ever
seen this one before; probably taken
around the 1930s of the emperor on a
hunting party with two of his sons.
And the wonderful train,
the [inaudible],
on the French-built railway line
from Djibouti to Addis Ababa,
which incidentally, the
route has been built --
a new railway has been
built by the Chinese.
So there will be a super-duper
fast link between Djibouti
and Addis Ababa fairly soon.
This one, though, was this
wonderful narrow gauge train.
And we're going to be mentioning a
little bit about the train later on.
So for those of you not familiar
with the history of Ethiopia,
think of a map, top-right, Horn
of Africa, next to Sudan, Kenya,
Djibouti, Somalia, that's where
Ethiopia is, in the 1930s,
a very different place
to what it is now.
And the emperor came to power
in his coronation in 1930.
But before that, he'd
been in power for 14 years
as crown prince and prince regent.
So he was not inexperienced
in domestic
and international affairs;
far from it.
But in 1930 around the
time of this photograph,
he had a massive coronation
in Addis Ababa.
Guests came all over the world, he
was announced on the world stage,
he was on the front
cover of Time Magazine.
Ethiopia had announced
itself to the world,
and people were beginning
to take interest.
So this is a backdrop
to the early '30s.
Within a few years, of course,
he finds himself manning
an antiaircraft gun
in the north of Ethiopia.
The Italians invaded in 1985;
why, Mussolini wanted a colony,
a fascist flag waving exercise.
He wanted to show his power,
and so he just invaded.
The Italians, of course,
were also smarting very much
after they were defeated at
the Battle of Adwa in 1896,
the first African army
to beat a European one.
And the Italians were
still very sore about that.
And the Empress Father, of course,
fought in that battle in 1896.
In 1935, 1936, it was a
bit of a difficult battle.
The Ethiopian army was out-gunned,
out-maneuvered, had worst equipment.
And so soon, the emperor had
to retreat to Addis Ababa,
and in a historic occasion statement
decision, he left Addis Ababa
for the coast to escape his
country, and to appeal to the League
of Nations, which Ethiopia
had joined in 1923,
quite an internationalist move.
The Italians had supported this
move after the initial reluctance.
UK government, of course,
opposed it.
We'll see this as something
of a theme.
I have to apologize
for my government
in the 1930s, but there we go.
And so he had a council of
ministers, and they decided, "Yes;
let's promote the case of
Ethiopia at the League of Nations."
The emperor goes there in person
and he can be a figure head
of the opposition to
the Italian occupation,
and he could speak up for Ethiopia.
So he decided to leave, going
against thousands of years
of Ethiopian history where kings
and rulers either died in battle,
or on some occasions, even committed
suicide rather than be captured.
So this was a modern
decision, you might say.
It's an extraordinary story we
don't have time to go into today
of how the emperor and his family
left Addis Ababa on a train
like we saw, worried about Italian
bombers maybe attacking them.
And they went to the Port of
Djibouti where a British ship ended
up had been arranged
to pick them up.
Now, the catching of
the ship, which goes --
to those of you who
are "Star Trek" fans,
the name of this boat
was "HMS Enterprise."
And believe it or not,
there was a captain's log.
Captain Morgan kept a
log, which I have read
in the queue national archives
in the UK, an extraordinary diary
of this event, of picking up --
he was told to expect
12 guests, 12 visitors.
When he arrived and when he saw
the [inaudible] side at Djibouti,
he found 150 people, more than
100 cases of [inaudible] dollars,
that was the currency they used in
those days, the European currency,
two lions, a dog, a
Cadillac, a Buick,
and a lots of people running around,
saying they needed to escape.
So after much negotiating
and discussion,
it was agreed he would
take 50 people.
The lions didn't make
it onboard, the dog did,
the cases of [inaudible],
they made it onboard as well.
And an extraordinary journey as the
boat went up through the Red Sea,
people on the shore would follow the
ship by motorbike, other boats came
after it, and he eventually landed
in Haifa in what is now known
as Israel, and went to Jerusalem.
While he was on that ship,
according to the captain's log,
there was much discussion
between British naval authorities
and the emperor as to
where he should go.
It seems pretty clear he'd had some
injuries in the war in the North
with some poisoned gas
injuries, and he was --
he was thought at one stage to
go for treatment in Germany.
The empress wanted
to go to Jerusalem
to join the Ethiopian
community there.
But there were discussions about
the emperor coming to Britain.
Now, the British government
was like many governments,
torn between showing interest
and doing the right thing,
and being open to what
should happen.
The big issue was they didn't want
to upset the Italian government.
They thought Mussolini
might go towards Hitler,
which of course, he eventually did.
But they didn't want that to happen.
But equally they knew that
Ethiopia had suffered injustice,
had been invaded, and the public
opinion in Britain was keen
that the Ethiopians were supported.
So they tried to have it both ways.
They said he could come,
but he could only come
under certain conditions, only
bring a small party of diplomats,
and that he couldn't engage
in political activity;
and that he couldn't be
given an official welcome.
So this is the captain's
log, by the way.
It does exist, five pages of
sheer historical amazement.
Here is the emperor.
See, I'm already failing; I
haven't been able to chew gum
and walk down the street.
Here he is in Jerusalem,
these wonderful photos.
And here he is in Gibraltar
on the way to the UK.
He was given British naval
protection until Gibraltar,
and then the government
said, "No; you can't arrive
on British shores on
a British ship."
So he had to transfer to a
civilian passenger liner.
Such are the [inaudible]
international diplomacy.
Here he is arriving.
I'm sure some of you here know some
of these other figures
in these photographs.
Some of you here will know a lot
more about this history than I do.
So apologies for my -- if
I make any mistakes here.
So but here he is at Southampton,
arriving on the wonderful
Orient Line.
So that's why he ended
up in Britain,
to get away from the Italians,
to use it as a base to speak
to the League of Nations
in Switzerland.
And of course, Britain then
was a major world power,
and it was a good base to
have to manage to do some sort
of politic [inaudible], but I would
say under the counter, as it were.
The emperor gets to London.
Here is the reception from
the British people; big crowd.
This is Princess Gate near
Harrods in [inaudible] Bridge,
very convenient for shopping,
but just opposite Hyde Park.
It's actually just up
the road from here is
where the current Ethiopian
Embassy is as well.
And keeping the American connection
going, JFK lived somewhere
on this street when
he was a student.
So look at the reception here.
This is -- oh from the top,
but you can see the balcony
where the Royal Family were.
And it caused major attention.
This was big news in Britain
and around the world,
the Italian invasion.
And, of course, as we
saw, it actually --
some people argue was the
start of the Second World War.
You can make that case.
So it was a big international news,
and he was big news in the UK.
Here it is, I love this photo of
the old London taxi being greeted
by what's his face, Anthony Eden,
the British foreign secretary
at the time, Lord Avon.
Note the bowler hat has
already sort of assimilated some
of sort of British culture.
And if I was doing another
book, I would do the hat wear,
the headgear of His
Imperial Majesty,
because seeing what he wears
at different times of his life
and during this exile
period, it tells you a lot.
Anyway, here he is.
Here is Anthony Eden.
Anthony Eden was fairly
pro-Ethiopia.
The prime minister at that time,
Baldwin, was more ambivalent,
and his predecessor --
one of his successors,
[inaudible] Chamberlain was
less inclined towards Ethiopia.
Suddenly Baldwin himself
was embarrassed about --
he wanted to welcome the
emperor, but he didn't want
to be seen to be welcoming him.
And the emperor was taken on a
tour of the House of Westminster,
the parliament on the
banks of the Thames.
He went in there to the tea room.
Lo and behold, the [inaudible]
Baldwin is at the end of the room.
And when he sees the emperor,
he dives under a table
to avoid seeing him.
[Laughter] So actually it's British
diplomacy; we're very good at it.
And they also changed the
route of his motorcade
so he couldn't be received by
a lot of cheering supporters.
So there was the ambivalence
that he survived
in for the next four
years in actual fact.
But the people were
very, very supportive,
and the people of Bath especially.
Of course, its base in Europe
was to go to the League
of Nations in Geneva in June, 1936.
Some people say this was the
best speech he ever gave.
Some the Italian journalists
before it started tried
to drown him out with whistles.
Mussolini had put them up to this.
They didn't want him
to have a platform.
They said, "Well, we are
now the rulers of Ethiopia.
Why is he there?"
But anyway, eventually,
they were thrown out.
A Romanian delegate,
[inaudible], got up and said --
forgive my French here,
"[Speaks Foreign Language],"
"Let's get rid of these savages."
And they were duly thrown out.
[Inaudible], though, his government
thought they embarrassed them,
and he was sent into exile
after this, apparently.
Amazing times, the 1930s.
So anyway, he made a speech
and everybody nodded their head
accentually and said, "Yes;
Italian aggression very bad."
But within a week, the League
of Nations had actually lifted
sanctions against Italy,
and so his speech fell
on deaf ears essentially.
So suddenly it was dawning on
the emperor that he might be
out of his country
for some time; indeed,
maybe he might never get back.
Because that's what we have to do,
we have to suspend our knowledge
of what happened in rest
of the 20th century.
This story -- we have to see
through the emperor's eyes.
He had no idea when
he would get back.
And of course, he did.
But it could have been different.
The areas where some of his
aides and advisors, [inaudible].
He goes back to the UK, and
people like making statues of him.
This is by Hilda Seligman, who
he stayed with in Wimbledon.
She was a sculptress.
It's now in Cannizaro Park, and when
I took this photo about a year ago,
it was restored a few years ago, but
it needs probably restoring again.
The emperor, believe it or not,
entered into British cultural life.
I looked through many
reports about his time there.
He was a favorite for a costume
at many fancy dress parties
that Britain had, [inaudible]
of Britain.
People would go dressed
as Emperor Haile Selassie.
He was in the fashion pages
for his capes and shawls.
And there's a wonderful --
at the same time in 1936,
this is by Epstein, the American
British sculptor; wonderful.
And another here I like
here by a Serbian sculptor.
So he was still famous, and people
were still following what he was
up to.
This is Bath Abbey.
Why did he go to Bath?
Well, it seems he went, first
of all, just for a rest.
He'd been at war, he'd
been to Europe,
under a lot of stress and strain.
Someone recommended that he go
to Bath in the west of Britain,
100 miles west of London,
a spa city, a Roman city.
And the irony of that,
turning up in an Italian city,
having fled from the Italians.
Also, a famous city for its
18th century architecture;
people come from all
over the world to see it.
This would have been
the view from the train.
He went on the train built
by the wonderful British
engineer, Isambard Kingdom Brunel.
The line is still going
today strong.
On this site in 973
AD, the first king
of all England was crowned king.
So quite an auspicious place.
This is not my house, [laughter],
neither is it the emperor's house.
This is the wonderful royal
present, Palladian architecture,
balanced proportion
harmony, [inaudible].
You'll see it there.
[Inaudible].
So the wonderful Marlboro buildings,
His Imperial Majesty took
his dog for a walk near here.
He was being spotted
here definitely.
So these wonderful buildings; one
of the few bridges in the world,
Pulteney Bridge that
has working shops on it.
When he first came to Bath,
the emperor, in August 1936,
this would have been
the route to the hotel.
He stayed in a hotel,
first of all, for a month.
He wasn't going to settle there,
he just came for some leave,
and some rest and recuperation.
And you see these elegant
-- this is the canal,
but it's not the Manchester
Ship Canal.
This is a sort of elegant
[inaudible] canal,
very close to the hotel
where he stayed.
The Bath Spa Hotel where the
emperor, his three eldest children,
one or two advisors stayed for
the month they were in Bath.
This was state-in-the-art
in those days.
It had 100 rooms, 60 with hot and
cold running water, an orchestra,
a ballroom, and several
acres of grounds.
And the emperor made
quite a stir there.
So that his daughter, Princess Sahai
[phonetic] one day at the ballroom,
she was invited to dance by
a young English gentleman;
she was 16 or 17 at the time.
One of the emperor's
advisors, Dr. Bian [phonetic],
who eventually ended up living in
America, was worried about this
and said to her, "Princess, I
think it's maybe time for bed."
And she was with a British lady,
and the British lady said,
"Oh, come on, it's fine.
I'll look after her.
It's no problem."
Dr. Bian went off to see the emperor
said, "Your daughter's dancing
with this young English gentleman.
And apparently the
emperor just laughed,
fine he wasn't that
worried about it.
[Laughter] And in May when I had
the British version of the book,
we had an event to
celebrate 80th anniversary
of His Imperial Majesty's
arrival in Bath.
And we dug out this
iconic photograph
with the then mayor of Bath.
A day after he arrived, August
the 5th or 6th, the mayor of Bath,
James Carpenter, they stood on
the steps of the Bath Spa Hotel.
I have a friend who used to
be in the army and he said,
"What is the emperor carrying?
I'm going to read that."
And he's been studying it in
microscopes, but he hasn't been
yet able to discover what it is.
I think it's probably a postcard.
So 80 years later, we
had a wonderful event;
over 100 people came.
The high sheriff of Somerset,
the local NP, the local head
of the council, some people
who were in Bath alive
at the time the emperor was there,
and we recreated this photograph.
This is Prince Michael, one
of the emperor's grandsons,
and this is the great
niece of the mayor of Bath.
So we recreated this history.
So it's living history,
as indeed we are today.
Princess Zeble was actually --
not at this time, she came
to Bath a year after this.
She was in Jerusalem at the time,
and then came a little bit later.
But we are -- you know, we have
in the audience, someone who lived
through this exile period.
He was very well-received everywhere
he went in Bath at this time.
These are not Nazi salutes,
I think people are --
it's just the greeting
that people had.
[Laughter] So he went to the
royal bath for some treatment.
And I've seen in the book,
he had Tivoli [phonetic]
treatment, whatever that is.
I haven't been able to
discover what that is, but --
and behind him in the
beret is Princess Sahai.
And he was offered the chance to
escape in secret and said, "No;
I'll come out in the front."
And so he was well-received.
People were pleased to see him.
And he went on a tour of Bath.
Of course, being the lion
of Judah, he liked lions.
And actually the city
of Bath likes lions.
It's on the coat of arms.
There are many -- more than 500
statues of lions in Bath itself.
This is one of them at
the Royal Victoria Park.
And this may be one of the
reasons why the emperor maybe felt
at home in Bath.
It's quite a royal,
elegant, regal city.
The people give him
a good reception.
He was beginning to realize he
may not go back soon to Ethiopia.
He was running out of hard cash.
His advisor said, "You
can't afford to keep living
in all these expensive
hotels and traveling around.
You need to make a base."
So he maybe thought about
maybe going to Switzerland
and settling there, but the Swiss
said they didn't want them there;
they were neutral, and
next door to Italy.
And so he decided to
stay in Britain.
London was a possibility, but
maybe too close to the government.
So Bath became suddenly
a real possibility,
because of its royal heritage,
pleasant place, only two hours
on the train from London so
you could still get to London.
Property was cheaper
there, of course.
And it was a convivial
place to be, maybe.
And so this is empress
with him here.
By October 1936, they bought
a house and they bring some
of the rest of the family.
This is the house, Fairfield House,
actually an Italianate villa,
another irony, built around
1850, two acres of grounds,
some big bedrooms, but not a palace;
I mean, just a big family house.
They are the royal couple.
We think this is the outbuildings
of Fairfield house in Bath,
and probably taken in 1937, 1938.
Some of you will know
some of these people.
I'm sorry to say Princess Zeble
-- the photographer was very bad,
so she's at the bottom
with half her head cut off.
Apologies.
They wouldn't have known all
these years later that --
and some of these will be
known to you in the family.
So they were there
together as a family.
And, of course, during the summer,
the weather's not bad and so,
you know, you can play some
tennis and table tennis
and Prince [inaudible]
would go around on his bike.
This is an old photo I dug out.
Sorry for the quality.
This is Princess Ida, another
grandchild, going to school
in Penzance in the
southwest tip of Britain.
So some of the grandchildren came.
They had to be looked after, and
educated, and everything else.
Why I've been able to find
some of these photographs is
that in Britain, we
have the lottery scheme,
and they put money
into cultural projects.
And they -- in 2012, they put money
into developing regional
newspaper archive
from the year, I think, 1750.
Between 1750 and 1949, many regional
newspapers have been put online,
and they're searchable; incredible.
So you put in "Emperor
Haile Selassie,"
and all of these entries come up
from the Dundee Evening [inaudible]
and the Nottingham Evening Post,
which we would have never been able
to -- I wouldn't have even
known they were there.
But we found all sorts of
things, all sorts of photographs,
even the fact that he tried kippers,
if you know what kippers are,
sort of herring, smoky
fish; even tried some
of those apparently, so we're told.
Because many diary
items were written
about the emperor and his family.
He was still new.
Some people wanted to
know what he was up to.
And in 1936, still had some
cash, so here is a [inaudible].
In the car is Prince [inaudible].
I think he's too young to
drive it in the moment,
but there's the man
from Bath Garages.
The emperor, of course, as you
probably know, he loved gadgets,
and planes, and clocks, and
watches, and cars, [makes sounds].
Now, in the grounds of
the garden, of course,
the Orthodox faith very important.
There was no church --
Orthodox Church in Britain.
What there was, was a greenhouse,
and at the time, the emperor wrote
to the church in Ethiopia
-- church in Jerusalem,
and arranged for a tabot
[phonetic] or a concentration stone
to become over to the greenhouse.
So they made this into their church.
It no longer stands today, but that
was the couple of priests there,
and there were services
regularly to pray for the country.
Of course, while the emperor
is there, he's obviously aware
of what is going on in Ethiopia,
and a lot of the news is very bad.
This is actually on the steps
of Addis Ababa University,
the palace -- it used
to be the palace
where the emperor set
off from for his exile.
This is the Italian
viceroy Graziani.
I taught -- this is a campus,
and I taught on this campus.
Here in beginning of 1937, he's
distributing arms to the poor.
But there's a plot to kill him.
Two people throw a bomb,
he's injured a couple
of people are killed, the Italian
army and the Blackshirts go berserk.
They mow down hundreds of
beggars, and women, and children,
and then go on the rampage for
basically four days killing maybe
as many as 19,000 people
over four days.
And so some terrible times.
This, of course, comes to the
Fairfield house, the news,
the Gloucester Evening Paper,
which is close-by to Bath.
They had an appointment with him,
but they said His Imperial Majesty
had to cancel the appointment
because of the distressing news.
And it was said later in a later
interview he gave a few years later,
this was the only time his
servants apparently saw him break
down in front of them.
So terrible news.
You're there on the other
side of the world powerless,
you can't do anything about it;
some people have accused
you of running away.
And then there was a whole
series of news of people he knew
who had been killed and murdered.
And this is a service in
London a few weeks later
with the foreign minister
and [inaudible], his cousin,
and the London representative
for Ethiopia.
Now, of course, some
British people helped him.
Here's another bit
of living history.
This is a tapestry based
on a photograph taken
by a young boy called
"Richard Pankhurst."
For those of you who know Ethiopia
and for those in the library
and studies business, Richard
Pankhurst is the founder
of the Institute of
Ethiopian Studies.
His mother was Sylvia Pankhurst
of the famous Pankhurst
suffragette family.
And she took to the
emperor and his cause.
Even though she was opposed to the
idea of royalty and the monarchy,
she wanted to support him because
of what the Italian government had
done, and she was speaking
out for freedom.
So she went to visit the
emperor at Fairfield House.
This is his friend
in the background.
And so an angle like this is
taken by an eight-year-old boy,
Richard, who is still alive.
So I talked to Richard about
this, he took this photograph,
and she was one of many
British people who rallied
to the cause and supported Ethiopia.
And see if you can spot
Princess Zeble on here.
This is at the wedding of
Richard Pankhurst and Rita,
his wife in the middle there.
They still have this house
in Addis Ababa to this day.
This is [inaudible] next
to the emperor, who --
again, they're there
in Central London.
And David Greta, thanks to him
for facilitating my visit here.
This is his father, [inaudible]
Greta, with the emperor.
So this is Sidak [phonetic],
the foreign minister's son,
one of his sons who
was also in Bath.
So there's a whole range of
characters who themselves were
in exile, and had to suffer being
away from your own country, losing,
you know, identity, not knowing
what was going to happen next.
So you can see this is
basically a map I put together
of where the emperor went
during his stay in Britain.
He didn't just say in Bath.
He did go -- you see these
points in the southwest.
He opened many faiths and festivals
you see on the south coast.
He went to various places
to have a look around.
The tip of Wales at the bottom,
he went to a holiday home,
some people in Bath lent him that.
And then you'll see
he went to Manchester,
Liverpool where his
son went to university,
and right up into Scotland.
Many biographies of
the emperor and --
both in American English
basically just say the emperor was
in exile for four to five years.
He did the speech at
the League of Nations.
He went to Bath, and it
was cold and miserable.
And then he turned
up in Sudan in 1940.
So I've tried to fill
in these missing years.
He didn't just stay in Bath --
he was cold and miserable some
of the time in the winter,
but I can testify that during
the summer, it's pretty nice.
So he did get around
a bit, he did --
you know, and he spoke
at various rallies.
He did one in Cambridge,
north of London,
600 students wearing pink
carnations drummed their feet
as he came in to speak to them.
So people were taken
with this cause.
The didn't like fascism,
popular opinion,
and the emperor was an
embodiment of opposition to it.
But of course -- but now
we're talking about 1938.
It's beginning is dawn
on His Imperial Majesty maybe
he's not going to get back.
Bad news is coming from home.
The British government has changed,
the Foreign Secretary Eden
is replaced by Lord Halifax,
who's much more hard-lined,
much more pro-Italy.
And Halifax basically says, "Look,
we've got to recognize
Italy's occupation.
That's the reality.
That war is over, we've
got to move on.
King Emmanuel III --
Victor Emmanuel III,
he is the rightful
ruler of Ethiopia now."
And he suggested a meeting of
League of Nations to discuss this.
The emperor went this time
to make another appearance.
He was exhausted, he had
been ill, and he wasn't able
to complete his speech this time.
Lorenzo Taezaz had
to finish it for him.
And it was clear the writing was
on the wall that many countries
in Europe were going to
recognize Italy's occupation.
And this was clear that it
was very depressing news.
Here he is on the west
pier of Brighton.
Note now he's wearing Western
gear, the hats and the overcoat.
This is another bit of
headgear, [inaudible] White.
And the [inaudible]
White newspaper reports
that the emperor's coming here,
and he has been depressed,
so this is openly said in the press.
So it shows how quite
disturbing it was, really.
This I found in the
National Archive.
By the end of 1938, the British
government did indeed act
on their promise of recognizing
Italy's occupation of Ethiopia.
That meant the British government
did not see the emperor anymore
as head of state.
He was now the ex-head of state.
So they slapped him with
an income tax return.
[Laughter] I love it.
Yes; that's -- [laughs]
I don't, but --
then the emperor wrote to the king
1939 saying, "Look, I'm still here.
Don't forget me."
As war was coming in Europe, 1939,
he goes to a Bible college in Wales,
just before the world breaks out.
He gets some money from the
British government eventually.
Churchill becomes prime minister.
Mussolini declares war on Britain.
I'm going to finish in a second.
Churchill eventually
sends the emperor back.
And here he is in Sudan, entering --
I know this date, this is January
the 20th, that's my birthday,
just in case you don't know;
1941, the Dinder River,
he crosses the Dinder River.
There was some more British
government maneuvering while
deciding when to go into Sudan,
but he goes into territory here.
And now he's back in
Addis Ababa in 1941,
five years to the day after he left.
So it's time for questions, is it?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Pardon?
Yes. So far so good.
You're still following?
[Laughter] So here he
is with George Steer,
a wonderful British
South African journalist
who wrote a lot about the emperor.
The story and relations with
Britain and Bath were not over.
In the mid '50s, he
came back to Bath
to be made free man of the city.
We have this quaint thing in Britain
where you have these things --
where you can be recognized
to be a free man of the city.
In London, it means
you can drive cattle
across the Thames on a bridge.
And if you're caught for any
dismeanor, you can be hanged
with a silken cord
instead of a rope.
[Laughter] So it's quite
good being a free man.
Anyway, so he was a
free man of Bath;
this time big state
reception, huge turnout.
He gave these elephant
tusks to the city.
Unfortunately, they were
stolen a couple years later.
Fairfield House is still -- he
gave to the people of Bath in 1958.
It's still being use
as a community center.
And of course, he didn't
forget the people of Bath.
This is Fairfield Palace
in Debre Zeyit,
which he named after
the house in Bath.
And this is a picture I found
not long before his death
at Fairfield House.
Of course, those of you who
know the history, 40 years on,
things were very different.
And eventually, after being
murdered by the dirge in 1975,
after the dirge had deposed,
and a few years later,
the emperor's buried in Holy Trinity
Cathedral, which he'd completed
as a monument to his
victory over the Italians.
So in terms of my story,
his time in exile,
in some ways you could say it's
fitting that he is laid to rest
at this place, which symbolizes one
of his defining moments of his life.
Plus in the lead at the top, there
is a photograph of the League
of Nation's speech and debate.
So this exile period, this time of
fighting the Italians, was very,
very important in his life, I
submit, and is therefore worthy
of just thinking more than
he went to Geneva and Bath
where he was cold for four years.
So that's what I tried to
do, ladies and gentlemen.
So please, if you've got
any questions, please do.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Talking ]
I hope it's not too difficult.
You know, that's -- [laughs]
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Ah, well --
Yes; well, I mean, there are
some missing holes in the story,
but basically I've seen
some of the Cabinet papers
for the discussions they had
when Mussolini declared war
and the time running up to that.
And they analyzed would the emperor
gain support from the patriots
and from the people back home?
What -- how should we support him?
By this time, you're right, Eden was
back in the Cabinet by this time.
And I don't know the answer to that,
because I haven't seen
anything that said specifically.
The Emperor said that he had
been promised modern weapons,
and that he would be supported
very quickly to go back.
In the end, he ended
up nine months waiting.
And it was only sort of facilitated
where Eden himself would had been
promoted again the Cabinet went
to Khartoum, and basically pushed
the deal that led to the invasion.
So there were still factions
in the British government.
There was still opposition in
Africa among the British diplomats.
Some of them didn't want
the emperor to come back.
And, of course, as we saw -- I mean,
this is not the subject of today,
but more British sort of
government to-ing and fro-ing,
they really having in
their own eyes liberated --
or helped to liberate Addis Ababa.
They wanted to carry
on and run the place.
And the emperor had to
fight them not literally --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, they did.
Yes; it was British self-interest.
Churchill wanted to send him
to cause trouble for Mussolini.
He saw this was a way of doing it.
Yes; so this was a feature
for the next two years.
And this in fact led really why
the Ethiopian policy went much more
towards the United States
in subsequent years.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes.
>> My question is basically
the same, you know,
whether there had been any
negotiation regarding the ultimate
invasion while he was
still [inaudible]?
>> Keith Bowers: Well, I mean, in
the end, it was done quite quickly,
but he thought they weren't --
maybe weren't going to send him.
He did say to Sylvia Pankhurst at
one stage, "What are they doing?
Why are they delaying?
Why won't they send me?"
And later, Sylvia Pankhurst said
-- she wrote an article saying,
"I have to protect the emperor
from his protectors now."
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Sorry; missed some of that.
Is that --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes; it was to appease Mussolini.
Well, you could argue that.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes; you could make that case.
You could make that case.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Keith Bowers: There
was a tremendous amount
of appeasing, of course.
Yes; and I think that
the actual decision
to recognize Italy's occupation,
that was a betrayal, definitely,
when they said, "Well,
you know, let's move on."
But it was different times.
They were frightened
of war in Europe,
and it was a frightening
war, as we saw.
So no wonder they were
-- you have to try
and understand it from
their point of new.
I'm not justifying it, but
I'm saying they were trying
to make political calculations.
And in the end, even though public
opinion was very pro Haile Selassie
at the beginning, they began more
and more to be worried about Europe,
and Africa then seemed far away.
So British public opinion wasn't --
in some ways, the emperor was
becoming a little bit forgotten.
And maybe if Mussolini hadn't
have come back into the war,
he would never would have
come back to Ethiopia.
>> During his life, did the British
government ever make a formal
apology to Selassie
[laughter] [inaudible]?
[ Background Talking ]
>> Keith Bowers: No.
[Laughter] I mean,
there were factions --
as we said, there were
factions in the government.
They felt they were
pursuing the right policy.
And they would also point out and
say, "Well, didn't we supply troops
and actually get rid of
the Italians in the end?"
But no, we're not talking
about principle here,
we're talking about can do
politics, yes, that's --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Not very much.
No, not very much, no.
Later, they did.
Of course, you know, the
current queen was quite close
to His Imperial Majesty
and visited Ethiopia.
And when he came back in 1954,
he stayed at Buckingham Palace,
which was rather contrast
to how he turned up in 1936.
But no I think even in 1924 when
he came on a grand European tour,
the then king was a little bit
sniffy about receiving him or not.
There was quite a lot of
racism -- let's not cut a --
beat around the bush, there
was quite a lot of racism
in the Foreign Office and in
sort of establishment circles,
not just towards Ethiopia,
but towards, you know,
anybody who was not from
Europe, I'm ashamed to say, so --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
No. I mean, he wrote to
the king there in 1939.
I've seen, again, at the archives
in queue the diplomats have a big
debate about how should we reply
to this letter, because the
King didn't reply; you know,
the Foreign Office mandarins.
And some factions said,
"Well, we can't --
you know, who does he think he is?
We can't let him think
he can get back his power
on French and British bayonets."
That is what someone said.
So they did eventually try
and help him with his funding,
because they didn't
want the embarrassment
of the emperor going bankrupt.
That was one of the features.
I haven't really gone into it.
They were short of ready cash to pay
for the household bills
and everything.
They did find a benefactor who gave,
I think it was 2,500 pounds a year,
which is not a bad
sum in those days.
There was then a squabble within the
British establishment as to whether
that should be subject to tax.
The mysterious benefactor, Sir
William Collier, then collapsed
and died of a heart
attack on a train.
And there was another
[inaudible] over whether his legacy
to the emperor was then
subject to more death tax.
I mean, it was quite
extraordinary, really, the --
he was spied on by
the tax authorities.
And so I would say
no, I think we have
to understand he preoccupation
wars with the rise of Nazism.
You know, people quite
understandably, in some ways,
were not frequently straight, you
know, and the policy of appeasement,
as we know, turned out
to be an utter failure.
So no, I don't think it's --
I think the story of his exile
really you could say I think the
British people come out of it
pretty well in favoring Ethiopia
and justice, international justice.
British government was
sort of comme ci, comme ca,
I think we could probably say.
>> I think we have to end it here.
And please give an applause.
>> Keith Bowers: Yes.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.